the movie is set in the year 10 000 BC I
mean it better be otherwise I want my
money back and it revolves around a
tribe called the yagals they are
fearless people living in the mountains
with little to no idea of the outside
world all they do is eat sleep procreate
and repeat however with the sudden
climate change their condition
deteriorates the egals find it very hard
to hunt their only source of food
mammoths one day two Hunters returned to
the village with a small girl named
evolette it turns out she had been
holding on to her dead mother in her
Village which was attacked by Invaders
seeing her Misery the egal's respected
Elder and Shaman the old mother decides
to investigate she touches the young
girl hoping to learn her past but
shockingly the old mother is overwhelmed
with terrifying visions of the
four-legged demons which apparently
attacked evilet's Village she also
prophesizes that the same Invaders will
come after the egals soon and that
whoever kills the leader of the Demons
will will win both evelet and the holy
white spear becoming the next Village
Chief however the current Village Chief
doesn't believe any of this and instead
decides to take an alternative path to
feed his people so the same night he
leaves the village before giving his
best friend tick tick his white spear
asking him to protect his son delay the
next morning word spreads about the
chief's disappearance and he is painted
as a coward who can't protect his own
village because of this his son delay is
bullied by the other kids mercilessly as
time passes the boy loses all his
friends and the only person who talks to
him is evalette since she is alone or
two they quickly Bond and become
Inseparable the movie then fast forwards
many years into the future where an
adult delay and evalette eventually fall
in love with each other the hunting
season has almost arrived and the old
mother tells everyone how Karen will win
over avilet as he has become a decorated
Warrior of the tribe later a worried
evalette approaches delay and asks him
to run away together however the latter
is adamant on staying put and protecting
his people from the demons all of a
sudden a young boy from the tribe named
Baku announces the arrival of the
mammoths and so all the hunters get
ready for battle they chase after the
giant beasts until one of them
eventually gets caught in the Trap
however as the Hunter's approach to kill
it the mammoth suddenly gets up and
flees in the ensuing struggle it drags
some of the hunters along with it
including delay after a while the
mammoth finally frees itself from the
net and charges that delay however in a
shocking turn of events it accidentally
impales itself with a spear stuck
upright on the ground the other tribe
members arrived shortly after and praise
delay believing that he killed the
mammoth as a result the old mother hands
him the white Spear and also appoints
him as the new Chief as the hunters drag
the dead mammoth back to the Village
cheers of Celebration Echo across the
plains but delay feels sick with guilt
he can't accept the praise he's received
for something he didn't do turning to
his friend tiktek he confesses the truth
and seeks advice Tech a wise Elder of
the tribe and
great-great-great-grandfather of
tick-tock tells delay that accepting the
white spear through a lie is not
honorable and not the way of their tribe
so delay hands the spear over to him
determined to make things right but when
he confesses the same thing to evalette
she becomes angry and leaves the next
morning the old mother's prophecy
becomes true and the tribe is suddenly
attacked by the four-legged demons
revealing themselves to be just horse
riders the demons tear the village apart
and wreak havoc among the tribe they
also capture various tribe members which
they can use for slave work while the
leader of the Demons warlord notices
evelet and takes her for himself poor
Baku can only witness his mother
brutally being stabbed to death when
delay finds out about this he rushes to
help fight off the attackers but tick
tick stops him knowing that they are of
no match against the evil attackers so
delay is forced to watch from the
sidelines as this Village is ravaged to
Pieces he is even more heartbroken when
he learns that the love of his life
evilette has been taken away after the
invasion the survivors helped the
wounded while tiktik cow ran and delay
regroup and plan their next step they
are terrified of the four-legged demons
but also want to rescue their friends
before it's too late hence after a lot
of thinking they decide to pursue the
attackers even Baku joins them as he is
now hell-bent on avenging his mother's
death as the group sets out on their
Journey they discover scattered
fragments of evalette's necklace
reassuring them that they are on the
right track however their path takes
them through a treacherous Forest filled
with dangerous creatures it turns out
the demons are also in the same forest
and as they are moving a terror bird
suddenly attacks them one of the Demons
is instantly killed but before any more
damage is done the leader quickly rushes
them out of the area meanwhile delay
covertly follows them and arrives at
their makeshift Camp he is now waiting
for the perfect opportunity to attack
them however when evilette is harassed
by a demon member named one eye delay
comes out of hiding and knocks him out
he immediately frees her and runs into
the forest where they come across the
rest of the group unfortunately before
they can get far the demons spot them
and capture Karen the situation only
gets worse when the terror Birds arrive
and start attacking them in the ensuing
tussle tick tick is badly wounded so
delay decides to lure the birds away
from the vicinity he bravely takes them
deep into the forest and kills them one
by one however when delay returns to his
group he finds Baku and evil at being
taken away by the demons delay also
finds tick tick in severe condition and
so he builds a makeshift palette to
carry him along the way at night he
treats tiktix wounds and reassures him
that everything will be fine however
when delay goes to fetch food he
accidentally Falls inside a ditch
knocking himself out later in the night
it rains heavily and the hole starts to
fill with water suddenly a thunderous
Roar jolts delay out of his sleep his
eyes widen as he sees a massive
saber-toothed tiger glaring at him with
Hungry Eyes delay's heart races with
fear but as he gazes at the majestic
beast he realizes that it is suffering
and in need of help so with cautious
steps delay approaches the agitated
Sabertooth and freeze it surprisingly
the animal doesn't attack instead it
sniffs him curiously before bounding out
of the hold of Freedom delay also
manages to climb out of the cave and
returns to tiktik finding out that he
has regained strength tiktik reveals
that he heard an attack coming from the
distance and so the two head over to
investigate after reaching a deserted
town they discover some much needed food
and devour it hungrily but their feast
is cut short by the unexpected
appearance of a foreign tribe who
shockingly speak their language and
launch a sudden attack on them just when
all seems lost the same Sabertooth that
delay freed earlier emerges from the
Shadows bearing its sharp teeth and
roaring ferociously at The Intruders
everyone freezes and fear but to delay
his amazement the massive animal
approaches him calmly showing no
hostility as the tribe looks on in
disbelief delay realizes that his act of
kindness has earned him a powerful Ally
once the Sabertooth leaves the foreign
tribe finally lower their weapons and to
greet the two in peace later the leader
of the tribe nakudu offers food to them
and starts chatting he reveals that
delay's father had passed through the
town but was taken by the four-legged
demons following this nakuru leads them
to a nearby cave which is adorned with
ancient paintings the paintings tell the
prophecy of a savior a man who can
communicate with the saber-toothed tiger
and to lead their people to Freedom now
it has become clear that that man is
none other than delay we were waiting
for Jason Momoa but you will do so
nakuru immediately sends a messenger to
the other tribes he wants to prepare for
an all-out war against the demons but
delay is not so sure if he can lead them
the next morning the messenger returns
with some bad news he explained lines
that almost all the other tribes have
been invaded and ravaged by the demons
however the ones remaining have agreed
to fight for their freedom it is then
revealed that even nakuru's tribe was
attacked a few days ago resulting in the
capture of his son and the death of his
wife so without further Ado he along
with his men gather their weapons and
leave town they then Unite with the
other tribes who have come together to
Vanquish the evil demons once and for
all after a grueling Journey the Army
makes it to a river where they find
numerous boats filled with slaves
including evelet carran and Baku this
gives them a purpose in their mission
the specially delay who is now more
motivated than ever as the Army cannot
follow the boats through the river delay
decides to guide them through the desert
unfortunately the plan turns out to be
fatal as after several days of walking
they find out that they have lost their
way the condition becomes so severe that
many of them start collapsing due to
dehydration however the Army still
doesn't give up and keeps pushing with
all their might their hard work
eventually pays off when they discover
an advanced civilization a place known
as the mountain of the gods they also
find out that the people who were
kidnapped are used as slave labor to
build pyramids into other monuments yeah
yeah right we all know it was aliens who
did that the land is ruled by an
enigmatic leader called The Almighty who
everyone fears as an Untouchable and
ruthless God the same night delay and
nakuru stealthily make their way into
the slave cages the plan is to Rally
their fellow captives and form a
rebellion against their oppressors
nakuru is Overjoyed to reunite with his
long-lost son but delay's heart sinks
when he discovers that evalette is being
held in another Castle I mean building
as they try to gather support for their
cause a slave from another tribe steps
forward and angrily protests warning
that delay's recklessness will get them
all killed however nakuru has a surprise
up his sleeve that leaves everyone stunt
he claims that delay has the ability to
communicate with the Fearsome
saber-toothed tiger and that he is their
only hope of Freedom then a blind slave
steps forward and explains that the
almighty can only be killed by a person
who has the mark of the hunter as the
conversation continues delay and nakuru
hear the sound of approaching guards so
they quickly make their escape from the
slave cage however their escape is not
unnoticed and the guards follow them
into the desert tiktik arrives to their
rescue and valiantly defeats the enemy
single-handedly unfortunately he
succumbs to his injuries as well
devastating delay later that night the
warlord attempts to assault evalette but
he is soon discovered by one of the
almighty's priests this leads to his
arrest as he took a slave without
permission the priest then notices the
scars of evilette's hands and discovers
the mark of the hunter on her shocking
him meanwhile delay finally gets over
tiktik's death that was fast and accepts
the white spear given to him he then
steps up and decides to form a rebellion
with the remaining tribe members and
makes his way towards the city the next
morning the tribe members blend in with
the slave workers and prepare to attack
the guards delay also reunites with
Karen uh Karen and the two get ready for
the first stage of their plan which is
to release the mammoths and as soon as
they do so Havoc ensues this serves as
the perfect distraction for the rebels
and they finally cause an uproar many
guards are killed brutally but some
Rebels also lose their lives including
Karen just then the almighty comes out
of hiding and threatens to kill evil Ed
if they do not abandon their Rebellion
left with no choice delay feigns
acceptance but then abruptly hurls his
white spear towards the almighty killing
him and breaking his illusion of
Brotherhood everyone is shocked to see
him fall and thus all the slaves join in
on the fight nakuru also joins in on the
action and kills one eye by impaling him
with a deadly spear meanwhile the
warlord tries escaping with evilet on
his horse but she cheekily stabs him
causing them to fall to the ground delay
runs towards her with relief but before
we can reach her the warlord shoots an
arrow through her back fatally wounding
her devastated by what he just saw delay
rushes to the warlord and finishes him
off mercilessly he then holds evalette
in his arms as she slowly passes away
however in a dramatic turn of events she
comes back to life it turns out the old
mother saw everything in her dreams so
she used all of her powers to reanimate
evalette in return however she gives up
her own life that's okay she was old
okay meanwhile all the Warriors and
slaves gather around to celebrate their
Victory the war is finally over in the
final scene all the tribe members
returned to their Villages and bid
farewell to the yagas nakuru hands some
seeds to delay revealing that his father
had collected them before he disappeared
plant them and they will grow you a new
dad this proves that the ex-chief did
not abandon his people after all days
later the yagas finally reached their
Village and plant the seeds in no time
the place becomes filled with Greenery
and abundant food subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching